احتفظ الديمقراطيون بالاغلبيه البسيطه في
مجلس شيوخ الامريكي بعد فوز مرشحه الحزب
كافرين كورتيزماستو بمقعد المجلس عن ولايه
نيفادا يملك الديمقراطيون حاليا 50 مقعدا
اضافه لوجود صوت نائبه الرئيس الامريكي
كمالاهارس التي تتراس مجلس الشيوخ مقابله
49 للجمهوريين ما يمنح بيضا بحسب ملاحظين
فرصه افضل لتنفيذ السياسه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الاعزاء كان ذلك خبر
القائم
وعلى اي نحو ستؤثر تلك النتائج على سياسه
الاداره الامريكيه تجاه القضايا الساخنه
بمنطقه الشرق الاوسط خاصه فيما يتعلق
بالملف النووي الايراني والقضيه
الفلسطينيه بوجود اليمين المتطرف في سبه
الحكم باسرائيل وعلى الاستقرار في مختلف
دول المنطقه
وكيف يقرا الامريكيون هذه النتائج
بابعادها الداخليه في ضوء عدم تحقق ما
سماه الجمهوريون مدادا احمر وما حجم
تاثيرها على برامج اداره بيض على الصعيد
الداخليه
[موسيقى]
لم يجعل ذئب ولم يشتكي الراعي في النتائج
الحصله الى حد الان من انتخابات التجديد
النصفي في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
بدانا الاكيده في نظري كثير هو انه ومع
احتفاظ الديمقراطيين بمجلس الشيوخ
وحرمالهم الجمهوريين من تحقيق الافتتاح
الانتخابيه الذي لوح به الاكيد هو ان
الاداره الديمقراطيه تمر نحو نصف فان من
عهده الرئيس
بتفاؤل يفوق الهواجس التي خشيت من ان تقول
مراكز قرار الى الجمهوريين ما قد يحول دون
بيض والمضي في سياسته الداخليه والخارجيه
عبر عن مواصفاته او بالسعاده البالغه
بنتائج الانتخابات النصفيه قائلا انها
عززت وضعه سياسيه قبل لقائه نظيره الصيني
جيمنج خلال قمه العشرين التي تستضيفها
اندونيسيا
لم اتفاجا واشعر بفرحه غامره ان يكون لنا
51 مقعدا في مجلس الشيوخ امر محمود لانه
يخدمنا في اللجان بكل بساطه وانا واثق من
ان الديمقراطيين قادرون على الاحتفاظ
بالاغلبيه في مجلس النواب
طبعا الحزب الجمهوري اقتبسوا ما سمعته
عندما قال احدهم ان ترامب كشف حقيقه تلك
التشكيله السياسيه وانا ادعو ذلك الحزب
الى ان يعيد تعريفه هويته ادرك انني اقوى
قبل لقاء سجن بينك واعرف الرئيس الصيني
وقلم وقع سوء تفاهم بيننا ولا طالما اجريت
مباحثات صريحه ليس فيها سوء تقدير البته
امام مركز احتساب الاصوات الرئيسيه ماري
كوبا لولايه اريزونا للمطالبه باحتساب
جميع الاصوات
للمرشحين الجمهوريين في ولايه اريزونا عن
مقعد مجلس الشيوخ
ومقعد حاكم الولايه وقالوا ان كاريك
المرشحه لمنصب حاكم الولايه
هي الفائزه
[موسيقى]
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنى من واشنطن ادولف
وافرانكو المحلل والاستراتيجي في الحزب
الجمهوري ومن واشنطن ادوات المسؤول السابق
في اللجنه الوطنيه
للحزب الديمقراطيسي معك سيد ادوارد جوزيف
عن انعكاسات هذه النتائج على وضع الحزب
الديمقراطي داخليا في الولايات المتحده
وتحديدا على
النصف الثاني من ولايه الرئيس
ديزني
وحده الصف افضل وهذا ايضا عدد موقف الرئيس
الامريكي بايضا
ويخرج من هذه الانتخابات كما لو انه رئيس
ولد من جديد
اب صمود
المنتصر الفعلي في هذا الانتخابات
راحه في ولادته الثانيه وبالتالي هل تعتقد
ان
الحزب الجمهوري سيكون مكبلا وغير قادر على
الضغط في هذه المرحله على الرئيس ايضا
اكان سياسيا في الخارج او حتى
مشاريع وقوانين الداخل
واو كره بين ماتش ماتش
ان يكون اسوا بكثير انا اوافق ما تفضل به
زميلي ولكن اعتقد ان الديمقراطيين يبالغون
في تفسير ذلك بالنسبه الى السباقات
الانتخابيه في الكونغرس
فان 46 مليون شخص انتخبوا الديمقراطيين
والنظري الى خريطه الناخبين
النتائج تبقى بنفس الطريقه ولكن هناك
الكثير من الولايات التي هي جمهوريه اولا
مجلس النواب لم يحسم امره ولكن يبدو
جمهوريه يعني هذا يعني انا يخسر هذا
المجلس
الاحتمال الاكبر وطبعا هذا من شانه
اما بالنسبه الى مجلس الشيوخ في يبدو ان
الامور بقيت على حالها نعم هي ليست عمليه
الماده الاحمر التي توقعناها ولكنها لم
تكن ليله جمهوريه سيئه اذا نظرنا هيها
بصوره عامه كانت ليله سيئه بالنظر الى
انترنت تجديد النصفيه حيث عاده
نكسب مقاعد اكثر ما توقعنا هذا صحيح اعترف
بذلك ولكن هذا لا يعني ان هذا يخدم رئيس
بعيدا نعم هو بحاجه الى تجديد صورته سوف
يصير عمره 80 سنه هذا العام ولكن سوف
يواجه ان ناخذين بعد سنتين في سن ثانيه
ثانوي هذه المشكله كبيره وهو لا يقنع
الكثيرين حتى ذلك الحين نحن نود ان نتحدث
الان عن تاثير هذه النتائج وسابقى معك هنا
سيد رئيس ايضا يقول بانه سيكون اكثر قوه
خلال اجتماعه مع الرئيس الصيني وهذا
يقودني الى السؤال عن السياسه الخارجيه ل-
همم اداره الرئيس بيضا والتي كان هناك
انتقادات من الجمهوريين ويمنون النفس وضع
حد لهذه السياسات الخارجيه بشكل او باخر
وهذا ما قد لا يحصل معنى حققه
الديمقراطيون من نتائج على المستوى
الخارجي انا اقصد
همم
اعتقد ان هناك الكثير من الانتقادات
الجمهوريه ان الاداره الامريكيه ليست
قاسيه بما فيها الكفايه اتجاه الصين ونحن
قد يكون بشاني الجيش الصيني الذي يتنام في
المنطقه في العالم بكل صراحه بالتالي نحن
قلقون بشان العدائيه الصينيه التي تحصل
بطريقه غير مباشره في العالم وبطريقه
مباشره في تايوان بالنسبه لموضوع الانفاق
الموضوع يرتبط طبقات اوكرانيا هل فعلا سوف
نستمر
بتمويلي اكثر يعني الى هذا او بهذا الموسم
بدون التوصل الى حل انترلوماسيه يبدو انا
الاداره الامريكيه الحاليه تشير الى بعض
الضغط على الاداره الوكرانيا لدخول في
مفاوضات مع روسيا هذا ايضا يحضر
بانتقاد ديمقراطي ولكن بالنظر الى دعم
الاداره الامريكيه لاوكرانيا اعتقد ان
هناك قلق من الحزبين
واعتقد
ان
الجمهوريين سوف يستيرون على مجلس النواب
بالتالي الميزانيه المخصصه لهذه الجهود
سوف تكون تحت سيطرتهم وبالتالي لن يتمكنى
من ان يكون لديه اريحيه الحركه كما كان من
قبل
هل تتوقع فيما لو سيطر الجمهوريون على
مجلس النواب فعلا
الموازنه موازنه المساعدات المرصوده
لاوكرانيا
نعم
الجمهوريين الان في موقع او في موقف صعب
جدا ان النتائج هذه الانتخابات النصفيه قد
عقدت كثيرا
بالنسبه او عقدت وضع
وحاله رئيس مجلس النواب اذا كان جمهوريه
حتى الان لم يحصل الموضوع على معلومات
ليست مؤكده
رئيسه مجلس النواب سيكون من الصعب عليه ان
يوقف الانفاق لانه سوف يدخل في مواجهه مع
اعضاء من حزبه في مجلس النواب ومع
الاغلبيه
الديمقراطيه في مجلس الشيوخ لا يوافق على
ذلك
اذا سيطروا على مجلسا وسيكون وضعهم ضعيف
فيسيطرون عليه من وجهه نظر ضعيفه وهناك
الكثيرين من الذين يولون ترامب وهذا يصعب
عمل الجمهوريين الديمقراطيون من جهه اخرى
وهذا اساس السياسه الخارج الرئيس
مين بقوه كقائد قوي سيلتقي رئيس الصيني
الذي سوف يعرف ان الرئيس بيضا صارت لديه
قوه بفعل الانتخابات وهو القائد الذي لا
نزاع حول الانقراض
وانت وانت تتحدث هنا عن السياسه الخارجيه
يعني لابد ان نسالك عن هذه السياسه
الخارجيه ان كانت ستتاثر بالنتائج
الانتخابات ااه مع العلم ان هناك متغيرات
يعني همم حصل على الساحه كان فيما يتعلق
بالملف النووي
الايراني
بالقضيه الفلسطينيه
وهمم الانتخابات التي حصلت في في اسرائيل
وحكومه نتنياهو المرتقله لنبدا بالملف
النووي
باختصار هنا هل من جديد سيطر على سياسه
اداره الرئيس مع هذا الملف بعد الانتخابات
النصفيه
وين
ايران بالنسبه الى الوضع القضيه او الملف
الايراني الولايات المتحده صارت اقوال عن
الرئيس
اقوى في موقفه ويحظى بدعم كامل من حلفاء
في الاتحاد الاوروبي لانه حاول بنيه حسنه
ان يعود مره اخرى للاتفاق نووي مع ايران
وايران هي التي رفضت اذن الرئيس
اكبر هذا
يعني ان يصعب الوضع لكن ايران ليست الان
في موقف
يمكنها من خلال اي خطوات هي تعزل نفسها من
خلال توفير الطائرات المسيره والدعم لير
ادولفوا الفرانكو هل هل ايران بعد
الانتخابات النصفيه اصبحت اضعف مقابل همم
ان الرئيس بيدن اصبح اقوى في في هذا
المجال سيد ضده
اصلا
السيد لم تصلنا نتائج مجلس النواب بعد
ولكن اذا صار تحت سيطره جمهوريه كما هو
متوقع كيف يمكن ان يكون الرئيس اقوى بعد
ما خسر خسر مجلسا اساسيا فيه تناقش
الميزانيه في الكونغرس كيف يدعون انه صار
اقوى اذا خسر مجلسا وبخسر 14 موقع عيدان
في العام 2020 لصالح الجمهوريين اذن انا
لا اعتقد انه صار اقوى انا اعتقد انا
حكومه نتنياهو الان تمارس ضغط كبير على
هذا الاداره اضافه الى الحلفاء العرب
الذين وباسمك يرون هذا الجناح الايمن اول
يمين في همم اسرائيل وهذا من شانه ان
يمارس المزيد من الضغوطات على اداره في
تصرفه مع ايران لانه كان غير قاسم لبن
املنا اكثر من اللزوم تجاه ايران وسماح
لها بالوصول الى همم او ع- عزز قدره
وصولها الى سلاح نووي بالنسبه الى الحكومه
الاسرائيليه
فان اليهود في الولايات المتحده اقرب الى
حكومه ثانيهاه المرتقبه وبيت همم انا
اعتقد ان الحلفاء العرب في منطقه الخليج
سوف يكونون همم
اذا يترقبون ما يحصل لا اعتقد ان الرئيس
الان هو اقوى بالنسبه الى ان نتائج هذه
الانتخابات يبالغون في تقديرها هو خسر
مجلس النواب وضع مجلس الشيوخ على حاله كيف
يعتبر ذلك
نصرال سيناريو المعتاد وهو اكتساح الحزب
الذي يكون خارج السلطه لمقاعد مجلس النواب
ومجلس الشيوخ وبالتالي يعني همم اعتبر
المد الاحمر المتوقع همم يعني لم لم يحصل
سيد ادوارد
همم هل يعني الم تكن مزعجه تلك الاخبار
الوارده من اسرائيل اخبار الانتخابات وايه
وصول نتنياهو من جديد الى سده الحكم في
اسرائيل الان الم تكن مزعجه لاداره بيض
وضيفنا يقول ان حكومه نتنياهو المقبله
ستمارس ضغطا كبيرا على اداره بيضا في
كيفيه تعاملها مع الملف النووي الايراني
السياسه الامريكيه تجاه ايران تنطلق من
واشنطن وليس من اسرائيل البنات المتحده
ليست بحاجه الى من يذكرها من البلدان سواء
كانت المملكه العربيه السعوديه او
الامارات بشان الخطر الذي تطرحه ايران
الاساس في التعامل معها ايران هو الوحده
وحده الصف بين دول الغربيه
هكذا تم الضغط في الاساس على ايران من اجل
ان تقدم عدد من التسويات والتنازلات في
وهذا يبقى فحوى الاستراتيجيه الوحده
الغربيه وقد عزل الرئيس
قام بجهودا كبيره وعكس سياسه رئيس ترامب
التي تقضي به الانسحاب الاحادي من
الاتفاقنا جميع
الاتفاق الاقوى والمثالي ولكن هذا ضعف او
اضعف الولايات المتحده وليس ايران
الولايات المتحده هي التي وجدت نفسها في
عزله
هكذا صارت ايران
انا هنا اسالك عن عن نتنياهو عن حكومه
نتنياهو الاكثر يمنيه والاكثر تطرفا على
ما يبدو في تاريخ اسرائيل الى اي مدى
ستضغط هذه الحكومه ولها مؤيدون كثر همم
لدى موجود في الولايات المتحده الى اي مدى
ستكون عامل ضاغط على اداره الرئيس بيضا
والمعروف كيف كانت همم علاقه اداره الرئيس
بايدم ب- اا نتنياهو
سابقا
اولا اليهود ليسوا يعتمدون مقاربه واحده
في ارائهم في اسرائيل وفي فلسطين هناك
الكثير من اليهود الذين يتمنون رؤيات همم
حل للدولتين الكثير من اليهود بشكل يكون
في ذلك شان اسرائيل
ليس الصوت موحدا ان نتنياهو يسيطر على
اصوات كل اليهود هذا خاطئ كذلك حكومه
نتنياهم مقربه كثيرا من رئيس ترامب ورئيس
ترامب هو الخاسر الاكبر في هذا الانتخابات
وهذا هو وهذا هي نتيجه او الخلاصه بالنسبه
الى الجمهوريين هذا ما خلصوا اليه الرئيس
الاكبر
لبن يمين ثانيه وهو صار اضعف الرئيس
جمهوريون سيكونوا همم انتصار عن بالكاد
يسجل الاذان
فرانكو عذرا سيد ادوارد سيد ادولف
هل او بالاحرى من وجهه نظر الجمهوريين
ما هي العقبات التي ستواجه الرئيس بعد
الانتخابات النصفيه وفيما لو همم كان مجلس
النواب بيد الجمهوريين ما هي العقبات التي
يمكن ان تواجهها في السياسه الخارجيه اولا
وشيء من السياسه الداخليه باختصار
لمين اريد ان اجيب على السؤال المباشر
بالنسبه الى حكومه نتنياهو اسرائيل
تجاه الشرق الاوسط والقول انها تحصل في
خوائم او فراغ في واشنطن انا اعارد ذلك
صوت اسرائيل مؤثر جدا سيكون صوتا مختلفا
عن صوت الحلفاء العرب انا لا اعتقد ذلك
ومن يعتقد ذلك لا اعتقد انه يقول الامور
بكل صراحه وشفافيه مع كل احترامي بالنسبه
الى التحديات امام اداره وايضا فان مجلس
النواب بتسيطر عليه الجمهوريون
طب بريك
سوف سوف
يكسر موقف الاداره الامريكيه اي سوف يكون
في موقفا لا يسمح للاداره
وهذا من شانها ان يترك تاثيرا مباشره على
سياسه الخارجه وعلى السياسه الداخليه ليس
هناك
مكاسب لعدم السيطره على المجلسين انا
عملته في هذا المجال لا نحن همم
مع سته مقاعد في مجلس النواب من قبل ولكن
الامور كانت صعبه مع انه همم مع اننا لم
نخسر فعليا
شكرا لك عفوا ادولف فرانكو المحلل
الاستراتيجي في الحزب الجمهوري وشكرا
لادوار جوزيف المسؤول السابق في اللجنه
الوطنيه للحزب الديمقراطي كنتما معنا من
واشنطن انتهت حلقتنا مشاهدينا من برنامج
ما وراء الخبر الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]